il existe un peuple extraterrestre
appelé bouffe et parmi eux un petit
bonhomme nommé au salon qui voudrait
juste être comme tout le monde je suis
super star en technologique
voilà arrêter ce fou qu'il lui faut
trouver un endroit où se cacher qui va
me laisser entrer dehors là mais tu sais
tu as seulement à retirer ce morceau de
bois en avril mes amis ma fatigue et moi
oh oh j'ai été donné ce nom par mes
nombreux nombreux films d'animation
auxquels beaucoup de maintenant
ton véhicule et deux vestes etc c'est
mon chat voilà qu'il émet des vibrations
pas explosé il est en cavale
pourquoi ils cherchent comme ça je les
fabrique et quelques bêtises à georges
s'il est totalement dépassé et ce qui se
passe qu'a fait mon corps ça s'appelle
danser les books ne connaissent pas
danser la place va jamais survivre à
ceux dans certains endroits on se posait
par les créateurs des croûtes et de
dragons tu as vraiment cru pouvoir nous
échappe et il va détruire la planète pas
question de baisser les bras
il va changer sa planète hoth de
descriptions engagé non elle va
bouleverser son univers je ne suis pas à
ma place avec les pousse à personne
n'ait pas fait ce sont nos erreurs qui
nous rend du mans et les pauses pipi au
jeu doit aussi poser pipi comble
heureusement qu'il y ait un groupe de
citronnade route
dreamworks en avait fait il ya là je
balance les mains en l'air comme si on
avait rien à faire